bonsoir bienvenue sur le plateau de tv
fils pour le 7-8 une heure pour faire le
tour de l'actualité locale vous en avez
l'habitude de 18 à 19 heures en direct
avec de nombreux invités pour nous
accompagner à commencer ce soir par jean
pierre meriaux bonsoir à vous j'avoue
est le président du district de football
des yvelines avec vous nous parlerons de
la sensibilisation que vous menez autour
des accidents cardiaques qui peuvent
survenir sur les terrains des formations
que vous organisez également nous
aborderons aussi cette question de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires et de
leurs incidences pour justement les
clubs il va falloir s'organiser mais
tout d'abord cette première question qui
concerne le déménagement de vos locaux
vous allez rejoindre dans les prochaines
semaines saint quentin en yvelines
pourquoi ce déménagement
montigny-le-bretonneux plus précise oui
l or actuellement on est installé à
saint nom la bretèche depuis un peu plus
de 30 ans et à l'époque on avait 24
licenciés ont atteint 35 milles à
l'époque on avait trois salariés
permanents matin on en a neuf et les
locaux sont devenus enfin il sont puis
répondent plus ce qu'on attende locaux à
la fois pour le personnel et pour nos
clubs donc on a décidé déjà il ya pas
mal de temps de déménager on a enfin
trouvé ce qui nous convient à montigny
autonome et ce sera à partir de quand
alors on a trois mois de travaux on va
acheté les locaux dans quelques jours
et on a trois mois de travaux je pense
que le déménagement ce sera début
juillet kia meurillon district de
football des yvelines est l'invité du
cette suite de cette première partie du
7-8 vous restez avec nous en plateau à
nous allons découvrir à présent les
titres de cette édition il est à 18h05
si vous me suivez en direct la sécurité
aux abords du centre commercial skywest
espace saint quentin en question après
l'agression d'une policière le 8 mars
certains commerçants reconnaissent que
les tensions existent elles les
dispositifs de sécurité ont été
renforcées
les chiffres du chômage dans les
yvelines comme au plan national ils sont
en hausse au mois de février la
catégorie la plus concernée les plus de
50 ans le centre commercial parly ouest
à maurepas coignard à 40 ans un
anniversaire qui vient d'être célébré
l'occasion de se rappeler les débuts de
cette zone d'activités et tout ne s'est
pas accompli sans douleur et puis le
week-end de pâques approche une fête
importante pour les chrétiens également
pour les chocolatiers qui réalise à
cette occasion de belles ventes
indépendants aux grandes surfaces chacun
cherche à tirer son épingle du jeu et
pour évoquer ces deux derniers sujets
économie justement à désinvité ce sera à
la chronique de l'écho avec coeur
cambier bonsoir clair bonsoir alors
concernant pâques et les ventes de
chocolat nous recevrons sur ce plateau
un artisan chocolatier de
voisins-le-bretonneux mais également un
chef de rayon de chocolat d'un
supermarché de maurepas donc deux
acteurs bien différents mais pour l'un
comme pour l'autre
nous verrons que pâques est l'une des
périodes phares de l'année
et puis en deuxième partie de chroniques
nous parlerons des 40 ans de paris ouest
le président de l'association de cette
zone d'activités sera sur ce plateau
pour nous en parler lui racontera
l'histoire de cet espace économique et
nous présentera les festivités
organisées à cette occasion à la
chronique de l'écho dans une petite
demi-heure nous sommes avec le président
du district de football pour le moment
on va parler de vos différentes
actualités
tout d'abord est ce que vous suivez ce
boris vian c'est un programme que vous
suivez bon an mal an vous ne connaissez
certainement pas même gagnent c'est une
des candidates elle est originaire des
yvelines la rédaction l'a rencontré le
portrait est signée aurait lieu à
domicile
achat venait young and a fait entendre
sa voix candidate de l'émission the
voice on gagne est aussi yvelinoise
retour sur le parcours d'une chanteuse
pour qui une rencontre a tout déclenché
je faisais du stop et la voiture qui m'a
prise venait de prendre aussi
benji en stop donc on se retrouve tous
les deux à l'arrière et on parle comme
ça et me dit je fais de la guitare et
une chez ben moi j'aime bien chanter
peut être qu'on devrait essayer de faire
la musique ensemble un jour on se dit
tiens on va essayer et là c'était direct
la chimie et c'était évident mais il y a
cinq ans le duo ngan se produit
régulièrement dans des restaurants et
clubs branchés mais jamais véritablement
sur scène la participation à l'émission
the voice sonne alors comme une évidence
c'est une bonne exposition c'est
peut-être le moyen justement de
rencontrer les d'être opérés par des
millions de disques détourneurs des
labels c'est ce qu'on cherchait et pour
pouvoir justement passé à la scène c'est
ce qu'on veut avant tout parce qu'on est
prêts on est prêts on a déjà enregistré
deux albums en notre production
et voilà qu'on a on est déjà on est tout
près que nous montre juste pas le petit
poucet sophie qu'après cette industrie
la contrepartie de cette propulsion vers
le grand public et que désormais nous y
gagnent est seul sur scène qu'en est il
alors du lion c'était une bonne
opportunité une chance comme ça repart
faut pas la laisser passer
même si pendant un petit ange passe un
petit peu de vent jeudi il est toujours
là il m'accompagne tout le temps sur les
plateaux et pour moi je le fais pour
nous deux mingan réussi l'étape et
battle trois membres du jury sont conçus
il lui reste maintenant à se confronter
aux votes du public
une gagnera-t-elle la plus belle voix
voilà pour cette rencontre avec un jeune
gars mais si vous êtes amateur de ses
émissions on a appris ce matin que le
rappeur de trappes et la fouine serait
l'un des jurés de popstars sur d8 ce
sera dès les prochaines semaines les
castings débute le 2 avril
le principe est toujours le même créé un
groupe pas de commentaires encore du
principal intéressé si ce n'est une
photo postée en fin d'après midi sur son
compte twitter aux côtés des autres
jurés dont alexia laroche joubert la
productrice d'ailleurs de ce télé
crochet pour la fouine je cite il faut
s'inscrire cette année un pop star ce
sera du lourd cette année promet-il
tout un programme
le 10 mars dans le val d'oise un
footballeur amateur de 16 ans et demi
est décédée des suites d'un arrêt
cardiaque un accident survenu en plein
match sur un terrain et malgré
l'intervention des secours
un drame qui n'est pas d'ailleurs sans
précédent également dans le milieu
professionnel jean-pierre meurillon vous
êtes en charge du district de football
des yvelines ces dernières années vous
avez multiplié les formations médicales
pour les dirigeants les encadrants
également les entraîneurs pour qu'il
puisse intervenir au plus vite c'est un
problème de ce type devait survenir
vous avez été obligé de les mettre en
place ces formations c'est une directive
nationale lors la fédération en accord
avec la fédération française de
cardiologie a initié ce type
d'intervention de la part des instances
des concentrés de la fédération les
ligues et les districts et nous on y
adhérer donc depuis quelques années
effectivement ont fait quatre ou cinq
fois par an des formations qui dure une
demi journée dans lesquels on essaye de
faire passer le message auprès des
joueurs des dirigeants des arbitres des
éducateurs pour leur apprendre ce qu'il
faut faire dans un dans un tel cas
comment se passent ces formations
justement ce sont des formations très
technique on apprend à se servir des
défibrillateurs par exemple alors oui
c'est notre médecin daniel bissonnet qui
fait partie notre comité de direction
qui organise sa est essentiellement on
apprend les gestes qu'il faut faire et
les gestes qu'il faut ne pas faire et
d'autre part se servir effectivement
même si son savoir et réagir instantanée
connaître les bons gestes un tel drame
comme celui survenu dans le val d'oise
une quinzaine de jours c'est déjà arrivé
dans le département des yvelines dans
notre district oui c'est arrivé il ya
deux ans c'était un joueur de villennes
orgeval qui avait 20 ans et il a été
pris en charge par un de ses seins de
ses coéquipiers d'ailleurs c'était un
soir d'entraînement
qui était sapeur-pompier professionnel
et malgré ses anciens d'intervention
malheureusement il ya rien à faire
comment vous expliquez on a le sentiment
aujourd'hui que c'est peut-être plus
fréquents que par le passé ça arrive
dans le milieu professionnel par exemple
ça arrive dans le milieu amateur
convient de citer deux exemples val
d'oise et yvelines
comment vous expliquer qu'aujourd'hui on
assiste à la multiplication en tout cas
ce nombre de cas plus fréquents non je
suis pas certain qu'ils aient plus de
cas maintenant je pense que peut-être on
n'en parle plus parce qu'on essaie de
sensibiliser justement les gens à savoir
ce qu'il faut faire quand il se trouve
devant cette situation mais c'est pas
aussi peut-être un problème du fait que
c'est du sport et que le sport on ne le
fait pas aussi n'importe comment il faut
s'y préparer il faut avoir une bonne
hygiène de vie
oui tout à fait le sport n'est pas
dangereux mais c'est plus dangereux que
si on reste chez soi ne rien faire et
par conséquent il faut effectivement
essayé de faire en sorte de se préparer
d'ailleurs on avait une information qui
nous avons dû décaler qui était prévu le
23 mars où c'était justement comment se
préparer à la rencontre
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire qu'est ce
qu'il faut pas faire un avant comment je
préparais la thématique de cette
rencontre c'est l être humain pendant l
effort ans était le de cette réunion
effectivement ce n'est pas limitée
uniquement à l'intervention c'est
comment se préparer il faut se préparer
c'est un petit peu les mes consignes
aussi peut-être que vous donnez aux plus
jeunes qui s'inscrivent dans les clubs
de foot on leur apprend aussi à faire du
sport
alors on essaie de faire passer ce
message là parce que ça concerne aussi
non seulement la préparation mais
quelquefois aussi la diététique et dans
nos formations il ya aussi ça comment on
prépare une formation sur le plan
diététique
et je répète les gestes les gestes qu'il
faut éviter lorsqu'il y a une difficulté
c'est aussi l'éducation des parents
alors les parents mais pas seulement il
ya aussi les arbitres il ya aussi les
éducateurs il ya aussi enfin l'ensemble
des encadrants on va juste faire une
petite pause en parlions de ses
interventions justement au bord du
terrain faut-il rendre obligatoires les
cours de premiers secours c'est notre
question du jour
ah oui un délice et je pense que ça
devrait être obligatoire ce que je les
ai suivis et c'est très très important
et c'est une bonne idée parce que
finalement nous moi par exemple à
j'ai 20 ans de plus et je ne sais pas le
faire c'est quelqu'un dans le rer dans
le métro souvent les gens font des
malaises et ça permet de les aider tout
le temps à temps les secours arrivés ben
oui pourquoi pas effectivement sa part
est une bonne idée mais je pense parce
qu'on est un peu démuni quand il y en a
un accident devant soi ou quelqu'un qui
est dans les vapes
on sait jamais trop quoi faire quoi non
je pense que c'est plus efficace il ça
repose sur le volontariat quelqu'un avec
qui à qui on va obliger cette formation
et qui n'a pas forcément la vocation
d'agir en ce sens le frappent pas
forcément bien donc je pense que c'est
mieux c'est un robot sur les gens qui
ont fait le choix de suivre cette
formation est votre réaction est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec la dernière
personne qu'on vient d'entendre il faut
pas le rendre obligatoire faut que ce
soit sur le alors en tout cas dans le
football c'est difficile de rendre
obligatoire tout simplement parce que
les gens qui s'occupent de football ne
sont que des bénévoles et les bénévoles
si on leur si on leur impose des choses
ils seront tentés de ne plus de ne plus
consacrer une partie de leur temps à
nous aider dans dans ce qu'ils font pour
le football et dans le sport
saucier tandis notre rôle à nous il est
d'être persuasif d'être convaincant et
d'essayer de faire passer ce message là
on l'a bien compris en tout cas le sport
c'est la santé mais pas n'importe
comment il faut s'y préparer et de plus
en plus les clubs les districts de
notamment ils font attention on
l'a entendu avec vous on parle justement
par rapport à ce sport qui serait la
santé de multiplier les heures pour les
plus jeunes avec cette réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui doit leur
permettre d'avoir accès à plus
d'activités
ça veut dire aussi que vous serez plus
mobilisés parce que c'est une bonne ou
une mauvaise nouvelle pour les clubs de
foot alors il ya d'abord la question
c'est comment les choses vont se passer
parce que il ya une demi journée
supplémentaire de classe qui va être
à part soit à partir de 2013 à fin 2013
ou de la rentrée 2014
mais le problème il est de savoir si
cette demie jeunesse se situera le
mercredi matin ou samedi matin
et là dessus nous avons interrogé nos
clubs là il ya quelques il ya quelques
semaines nous sommes en danger attendons
les réponses de la part des différentes
collectivités des différentes communes
qui doivent prendre des signes décision
avant la fin devant la fin de ce mois
parce que le problème c'est que
actuellement nous avons des activités
sportives pour les plus petits juste
entre 6 et 12 ans qui se passe le samedi
matin
si ensuite l'année prochaine ou à la fin
de set
enfin la rentrée prochaine il y a école
le
ce jour là la question ça va être de
savoir comment on s'organise on
l'organisera ces compétitions
on pourra aussi interpeller les clubs
leur demander d'intervenir au cours de
la journée pendant la semaine
ce serait pas si oui je pense que c'est
certainement quelque chose qui sera qui
sera à l'ordre du jour lorsque le moment
venu ce sera mis en oeuvre
je dois dire que les réponses que nous
avons de nos clubs pour l'instant c'est
que la plupart des communes celles en
tout cas dont nous avons les réponses
la plupart des communes ont remis la
mise en oeuvre septembre 2014 n'ont pas
septembre ce sera le cas dans la plupart
des communes des yvelines même si encore
tous les conseils municipaux ne se sont
pas prononcés nous ferons bien
évidemment le point sur sur le
département sur notre secteur dans les
yvelines
nous vous donnons les informations pour
savoir si c'est en septembre 2014 11
septembre 2013
j'imagine que vous préférez septembre
2014 l'essm et ça nous laisserait ça
nous laisserait un peu plus de temps
pour nous organiser bien bien entendu
merci jean pierre meurillon président du
district de football des yvelines merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce début
d'émission encore trois quarts d'heure à
passer ensemble au programme les
journées de l'énergie avec les portes
ouvertes à rte dès demain et puis
l'appel à bénévoles du secours populaire
on en parle juste après ce point sur la
sécurité aux centres commerciaux espace
saint quentin et skywest ils sont
séparés de quelques mètres à montigny le
bretonneux après l'agression d'une
policière
le 8 mars certains commerçants
reconnaissent que les tensions existent
reportage d'anthony rech les images de
patrick jacques de dixmude nous sommes
le vendredi 8 mars aux alentours de 18
heures les policiers sont appelés sur
une intervention à l'espace saint
quentin une quarantaine de jeunes ils
sèment le trouble
une policière et blessé et ce n'est pas
la première fois on n'est pas sur un
phénomène de bande
comme on a pu connaître il ya quelques
années en arrière sur le parvis de la
défense
on est sur un rassemblement de jeunes
qui viennent parce que la structure s'y
prête vous avez des commerces vous avez
vous pouvez avoir des attractions
ludiques tels que le tel que le cinéma
est
l'effet de bond de bande peut
s'interpréter du fait que comme ils vont
se retrouver groupés et bien on peut
arriver sur des débordements mais ça
reste conclut elle
le malaise est en tout cas en train de
s'installer entre d'une part un centre
commercial sqy ouest vidé de ses
magasins et d'autre part un espace saint
quentin qui attire les squatteurs
certains magasins ont reçu la consigne
de leur direction de fermer boutique au
moindre problème
d'autres commerçants ne se sentent plus
en sécurité
je n'étais jamais tranquille le soir
quand j'allais chercher ma voiture au
parking
je demandais aux vigiles de
m'accompagner et j'ai même pensé à
déménager depuis l'agression les
patrouilles de police ont été renforcées
des vigiles recrutés de ségou et devrait
apparaître dans les prochains jours des
moyens humains et départ cent quarante
caméras de vidéosurveillance selon la
mairie de montigny entre 2011 et 2012
la délinquance au centre commercial
aurait baissé de 22%
c'est vrai que c'est que c'est pas
normal non plus d'avoir toujours à gérer
des personnes qui sont là pour nuire
donc tout simplement c'est au
propriétaire du centre de pouvoir
assurer une certaine sécurité aidées en
cela par la police nationale et aussi
par la police municipale de sion besoin
se faisait sentir
le directeur de l'espace saint quentin
hervé de niort doit rencontrer ce
vendredi le commissaire de guyancourt
pour faire un point sur l'enquêté
les deux jeunes agresseurs âgés de 13 et
14 ans n'ont pas encore été traduit
devant la justice